We're desperate to avoid it of course, but
we won't, for a lot of very good reasons:
We don’t understand ourselves
We're all crazy in very particular ways: neurotic,
unbalanced and immature...
But we don’t know the details,
because no one encourages us too hard to find out.
Our friends just want to be kind and have
fun with us. Our enemies don't want to waste
the trouble.
So we end up with such a poor level of self-understanding,
we have no clue who we'd be compatible with.
A standard question on any early dinner date
should simply be: ‘how are you mad?’
But it's so hard to know...
Secondly, we don’t understand other people
It's as hard to work out the craziness of
other people as it is our own, they put on such a good show
- at first.
What we'd ideally need is to send them and
us through a battery of psychological questionnaires
and have four years of intensive psychotherapy,
individual and couples' based - before reaching
a decision.
By 2100, this will no longer sound like a
joke - people will merely wonder why
took humanity so long to get us here.
We aren’t used to being happy
We think we want happiness, but what we really
want is what we're used to – and that usually
doesn't involve too much happiness at all.
Growing up, most of us had our love mixed
in with other, darker stuff: being controlled,
feeling humiliated, being abandonned or abused.
In short, suffering. And now, whatever we
may say, that's what we're mostly still on
the look out for.
It explains why we rejected all those candidates,
the well-balanced, mature reliable ones,
as somehow a bit 'boring'.
- and why we head instead with secret energy
to those characters we unconsciously know
will mess us up in such cosily familiar ways.
Being single is so awful
You have to be very at peace with empty Saturday
evenings, constant alienation and sexlessness
in order to be choosy in the right way.
No wonder most of us half shut our eyes and
grab what's there.
Instinct has too much prestige
Marriage used to be a rational business; all
to do with your parents matching their bit
of land with the neighbours'. It was horribly
cold and calculating.
So now we have romantic marriages. It's meant
to be all about how you feel. You should never
think too much. To analyse the decision immediately
feels ‘un-Romantic’.
Indeed, the most Romantic thing to do may
just be to propose really suddenly, perhaps
after only a few weeks - in a chapel in Vegas at 3am...
The madness seems a paradoxical sign that the marriage itself will be a sensible idea.
It won't be.
We don’t go to Schools of Love
We don't have any information.
We don't take classes, we don't talk to married
couples and steer very clear of divorced ones.
So we go into it without knowing why marriages
really fail – beyond what we take to be
just the simple stupidity of all those other
couples we're not like at all.
Freezing happiness
You want to make nice things permanent: you're
in Venice, on the lagoon, with no responsibilities,
the evening sun throwing gold flakes across
the sea, the prospect of dinner in a little
fish restaurant and your beloved in a cashmere
jumper in your arms…
You get married to make that feeling permanent.
But it all goes and what is really permanent
is the partner - but now in a very different mood.
You want to stop thinking about Love
It's such a pain: the heartache, the dating,
the one night stands...
You want shot of it all. You marry to stop
having to think about love all the time.
All of which is why you'll marry the wrong
person - or perhaps have done so already.
But it's not really your fault. No one ever
teaches us how to do this thing, and so of
course we crash.
We will, as a species, eventually learn. The
careless madness can't go on. Too many people
get hurt.
In a few centuries at least, we'll be getting
the hang of it - for sure.